avant un petit café j'ai tellement tu as
fait que le sommeil nuggets vraiment ça
vient ça vient j'arrive j'arrive ne vous
inquiétez pas jaloux c'est mieux donc
vous voulez monter comme un pro avec
final cut pro 10 chez ce qu'il faut
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour vous juste
après l'intro
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mans
encore une chaîne sur laquelle on parle
de création vidéo de montage mais si
c'est quelque chose qui vous intéresse
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner vous aurez
sûrement plein de choses qui vont vous
intéresser alors aujourd'hui c'est un
grand jour ça fait des mois que je vous
en parle j'ai enfin sorti ma formation
sur final cut formation qui s'appelle
réaliser des vidéos professionnelles
avec final cut pro 10 et pourquoi j'ai
utilisé le terme professionnelle et bien
tout simplement parce que c'est mon
métier je suis un professionnel de la
vidéo et je monte avec final cut logique
tu vois le truc et j'ai passé mais
vraiment des mois à faire ça j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps surtout à l'écrire
pour avoir quelque chose d'hyper
cohérent ayant un background prof j'ai
vraiment construit ça dans une
continuité et avec une structure la plus
pédagogique possible
ça part vraiment des bases de chez base
jusqu'à des choses assez poussée donc si
vous démarrez sur final cut ou si vous
êtes intermédiaires on va dire sur
quelques de scie où vous êtes formé un
petit peu sur le tard ça va être hyper
intéressant pour vous parce que dans
cette formation je vous donne tout mon
war flot de a à z tout ce que je fais
moi quand je le fais pour des clients et
bien je vous l'expliquais dans cette
formation point par point avec même des
extraits vidéos que vous pourrez
utiliser que vous pourrez pratiquer en
même temps que la formation avec ces
éléments là et ça va être vraiment
intéressant je pense pour vous de voir
tout ça et cette formation elle dure
environ deux heures et demi donc vous
dire si c'est complet il ya 40 modules
ça passe par l'import ça passe par le
décrochage le montage les effets les
transitions les bases de l'étalonnage
l'export bref on voit absolument tout ce
dont vous avez besoin pour créer des
vidéos au rendu trop avec un workflow
hypercard est hyper propres cette
formation vous allez la trouvaient sur
la plateforme eu déni je vous mets le
lien en description vous pouvez regarder
à votre rythme la formation vous n'êtes
pas obligé de faire les deux heures et
demie
un coup ça peut être petit bout par
petit bout moi je vous encourage
fortement à chaque fois que vous aurez
fait un module à mettre en pratique dans
final cut
d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas faim
quelques tabac vous pouvez aussi
télécharger la version d'essai sur le
site d'apple qui dure 30 jours qui vous
permettra de faire la formation sans
problème et puis après coup pourquoi pas
vous décider à acheter le logiciel ou
pas elle est au prix de 119 euros en
temps normal mais parce que je vous aime
bien que vous êtes mes abonnés chéri et
voilà je fais un prix de 50 % pendant
une semaine avec le code qui s'affiche
aussi dans la description vous rentrez
ce coupon là et vous l'aurez donc à 59
euros 99 au lieu de 119 euros 99 deux
heures et demie de formation 40 modules
voilà je pense que ça peut valoir le
coup et puis au delà de ça en fonction
du nombre de ventes qui aura su cette
formation ça va potentiellement me
libérez pas mal de temps pour youtube
par exemple pour faire d'autres vidéos
bien entendu cette formation c'est pas
la même chose que ce que vous trouvez
sur youtube c'est pas le même format
c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus
qu'un jeu beaucoup plus direct
on va vraiment à l'essentiel et il n'y a
pas de fioritures youtube c'est vraiment
de la vraie formation et je continuerai
à faire d'autres tuto sur youtube mais
qui seront vraiment sur des éléments
hyper spécifique hyper ponctuelles qui
n'ont pas forcément leur place dans une
formation vraiment sur des petits effets
très ponctuel et je continuerai à vous
donner du contenu sur youtube mais ce
contenu là celui de la formation
il est vraiment adapté à ce contexte là
quelque chose de carré et quelque chose
d'organisé pour vraiment avoir tout ce
qu'il faut pour bien démarrer
voilà je crois que j'ai dit à peu près
tous vous avez des hyper nombreux à me
réclamer sur un stade ailleurs pouvez me
suivre sur un style le lien qui
s'affiche dans la description aussi que
vous l'avez aussi réclamé sur twitter on
me l'avait réclamé dans les commentaires
depuis j'en parle ben voilà elle est là
je les fais tu pour vous j'ai mis tout
mon coeur j'ai mis quasiment tout ce que
je savais dedans et voilà donc j'espère
que cette formation elle vous plaira en
tout cas moi j'ai mis vraiment beaucoup
d'énergie ça fait des mois que je
travaille dessus pour vraiment vous
proposer quelque chose de qualité
là je vous laisse juge n'hésitez pas
aussi à noter la formation une fois vous
l'aurais fait et puis et puis on se
retrouve très bientôt il ya des vidéos
youtube en prévision là j'écris plein de
trucs ça va être ça va être pas mal donc
voilà je vous remercie d'avancé
et puis bien entendu vous pouvez mettre
le traditionnel coup deux blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo vous pouvez vous
abonner vous pouvez activer la cloche
vous pouvez partager
et puis dites moi dans les commentaires
ce que vous pensez de tout ça si vous
pensez prendre cette formation si vous
pensez voilà que c'est cool si vous
l'avez suivi et que ça vous a plu
voilà n'hésitez pas à me dire tout ça
moi je vous dis comme d'habitude les
amis rester curieux rester curieux de
rester curieux forme et vous et puis à
très bientôt sur une prochaine vidéo
et là je pense qu au nettement il va me
falloir du café en intraveineuse pour
récupérer parce que là on repart sur une
grosse période de tournage et a pas mal
de choses du montage a finir aussi parce
qu'il ya des choses que j'ai faites y un
ouf des semaines et j'ai toujours pas eu
le temps de monter parce que je vous
privilégiez vous des amis 1 et voilà
donc le sommeil c'est pas pour tout de
suite
c'est pas pour maintenant